everybody please welcome Gary well my
wife 9 just recently got married she's
perfect she's everything I ever wanted
and you know I'm having a little tiny
bit of trouble bonding with my new
stepson Lucas whoa look at that
thumb samarth worms good talking to you
buddy never really looks me in the eye
doesn't talk much except when he yells
at me to get out of this room turns
using this weirdo puppet thing I get
this sense that he's uh daddy's evil
incarnate
yeah remind me again how Lucas was
conceived you remember when I told you
about that crazy time in my twenties
where I joined that sort of like cult no
I think you told me about that doomsday
cult believed a child will rise up from
Hell to rule mankind and to bring on the
end of the world as we know it I think
we found that child and now you're his
stepdad there is nothing wrong with
Lucas he's very particular
he did this to me Newt will be that was
normal that all kids are dick that's
true kids are dicks man but this is the
sentient level
he's like top of the dick chain bro
[Music]
Wow
[Applause]
this is soon bro you gotta relax man I
relax we're in a cornfield so what good
thing has ever happened in a cornfield
ow oh no Field of Dreams is pretty cool
[Applause]
you